bonsoir les Russes on le disait pylône
le sud de l'Ukraine
oui troisième nuit d'affilée ou des
villes portuaires du sud de l'Ukraine
sont dans le collimateur des Russes
cette nuit c'était au dessin et Nicolas
Yves et malheureusement dans les deux
villes il y a des blessés et deux morts
au moins à déplorer puisque à Nicolas il
va un bâtiment résidentiel dans le
centre-ville a été touché au dessin
c'était un bâtiment administratif et
c'est le gardien du bâtiment qui avait
21 ans qui a été tué il y a plusieurs
personnes dans les deux villes conduit
être hospitalisés aussi même si c'est le
centre-ville qui ont été touchés
l'interprétation qui est faite par les
Ukrainiens c'est que cela reste une
tentative de la part des Russes de
cibler l'infrastructure portuaire avant
tout après cette retiré de cet accord
pour l'exportation des grands Ukrainiens
par voie maritimes la Russie veut
visiblement empêché l'Ukraine de faire
cavalier seul et de continuer à exporter
même sans les garanties sécurité de la
Russie donc c'est un signal très fort
que la sécurité ne peut pas être
garantie la Russie qui avait aussi dit
qu'elle considérerait dorénavant tout
navire à destination des ports
Ukrainiens comme potentiellement
transportant des armes et donc comme une
cible légitime si vous voulez et bien
aujourd'hui le ministre de la Défense
ukrainien a répliqué en utilisant
exactement les mêmes mots presque en
disant que maintenant l'Ukraine
considérera tout navire dans la mer
Noire à destination des ports russes ou
même des ports Ukrainiens actuellement
contre les par les forces russes comme
potentiellement transportant des armes
et l'Ukraine a aussi rappelé dans le
même communiqué que elle a la capacité
de détruire des navires et elle a déjà
fait de manière très notoire tout le
monde ici en Ukraine s'en souvient ils
ont même fait des timbres à l'occasion
elle a fait couler le navire Moskva le
navire le plus prestigieux de la flotte
russe dans la mer Noire à la fin du
printemps 2022 l'hiver où en est la
contre-offensive ukrainienne les
Ukrainiens utilisent désormais les armes
à sous-munition
observateurs et même d'officiel
ukrainien merci Gulliver direct de